[Music]
so let's go to heather and saint paul
what's up heather
hi hello
hello
hi
you know thank you for the light-hearted
cd talk that was i appreciate it do you
buy cds
well i mean i haven't in 15 years but
thanks for kicking me while i'm down
right
once you call one of those newfangled
shows they probably have is it the mp3s
or no they stream it now
so what's up
all right can i give you a little
backstory first absolutely
all right so my husband and i have been
together for 20 years okay we have an
eight-year-old son
we have walked through infidelity job
losses addiction miscarriages and my
mental health
issues of anxiety depression okay and
our commitment of marriage has kept us
going until a couple weeks ago he
blindsided me
and told me that he doesn't love me
doesn't know if he ever did okay and he
is tired of being the pillar of my life
he is
refusing any counseling he's only
surrounding himself with people that
he's known for less than a year okay
he says that he's excited to move out
and get a motorcycle and have space to
spend
time with our son
which i'm calling all the bs yep but i
can't be the one to call him out on it
okay
so how do i help him
and how do i minimize the tornado of
damage that is coming
to
coming my way in my son's way
i'm sorry heather
me too
yeah how long have you gone
how old are you
i'm 37. 37.
man
i was 17. yeah i was gonna say i've been
married for a long time why'd you get
married
well we didn't get married we've been
together for 20 years okay married for
15. okay all right
man
so
there's a lot lot here you you and i
could probably spend a couple hours
together i'm guessing right
yeah
yeah um there's a lot yeah
so
can i be super truthful
absolutely painfully so
yeah okay
to i'm gonna answer your question and
we're gonna work backwards together the
reason i don't like to do that is when i
answer your question i'm afraid your
body not you but your body is going to
shut off listening to anything else i
say
well i'm used to that so yeah
i'll try to stay with you stay with me
okay and if that means that you just nod
and say cool great good which has
probably been part of your survival
techniques the last 20 30 years um you
can just go back and listen to the
recording of this okay
okay
to answer your question there is 100
absolutely nothing
you can do to convince your husband to
do things differently
yeah zero you don't have that power
hopefully that is both terrifying and an
immense relief
because it's not a mad him leaving him
departing him running away
is about him not you
okay he will make you the bad guy
the same way when there's economic
crisis in countries countries rally up
and point at somebody or some group or
some other country as the reason
he has to have somebody to blame for
running
and you are that person
yeah
um
you were
you're a partner with him you're a
romantic partner so there's all kinds of
variables and this isn't that
but when he cheated on you
it was about him not you
when
he had addiction challenges those were
about him not you not things that you
weren't doing you get what i'm saying
100
and so
um the great
esther perel says most infidelity
happens because someone doesn't like who
they have become inside of this
relationship
not
because my partner's gained weight or
isn't pretty or whatever
i don't like who i have become in this
and so i'm going to go find
a that energy that electricity somewhere
else because i don't like me
and you just that's what addiction is
that's what infidelity is and now you're
telling me this is this mid-life crisis
i'm just gonna shake the snow globe up
and i gotta go i gotta i don't like who
i am in fact i hate who i am
and i'm blaming you
and that's gonna be my ticket out the
door because i can't just stand up and
say i need a break i can't stand up and
say i hate my job i hate who i've become
i am not exercising i'm not lifting
weights i'm not taking care of my mental
health i don't have relationships all my
friends have i've cut he can't say that
stuff out loud that takes a level of
strength and bravery he doesn't have
yeah and so
he he's and i hear me say his feelings
his fear his terror inside of him that
is 100 real
he feels the existential clock ticking
loudly so loud he can't sleep
um my guess is he's got demons that are
his entire lifetime old is that fair
yeah yeah he's been 100 he's been
running from himself for a long time
so you can't change that
and i
hate that for you because your life is
his life and his life is your life and
you have a sweet beautiful
eight-year-old tell me about this tell
me about this eight-year-old
he is
the most wonderful
little guy he is empathetic
and loving
and wants everybody in the room to light
up
and he dances through life and i never
want him to stop doing that yeah
so he will
this is going to be hard
gonna be very hard for him yes
and
you can't absorb this for him you can
hold his hand through it
and do you get the difference there
oh yeah
i'll give you a really extreme example i
may have even given this on the show i
was talking walking somebody through a
situation where
um
it was my uh somebody's close to me
their
girlfriend had a son sorry so it's kind
of removed the son did some terrible
terrible things and
the question was do we get a lawyer and
go through all this and try to reduce
sentence and get this guy off and i said
i don't want this human on the street
because i have kids
and my friend said you're exactly right
i'm 100 with you what do i tell this
grieving mother and it what i ultimately
said was
you can't keep him out of
the court you can't keep him out of this
process but you can hold his hand during
the sessions that's what a mother can do
and so
in a
sideways analogy here circling back to
you
your son is going to have a dad who
leaves
and that's going to put you in that
category you know what i mean
yeah and that like just being in that oh
i'm one of those
couples families now like that we're
that we're dead left
and because i was because the wife was
too much that story we've heard of it's
a cliche at this point
that's y'all now and he's gonna have to
experience what happens when a dad walks
out and dad says we're gonna spend tons
of time together buddy they're not
i know dad's gonna get into his
motorcycle and his new friends and his
new club until he falls off whatever
wagon he's climbed up on
and you know that
and my guess is if he's struggled with
infidelity and with dishonesty and he is
i mean with infidelity and with
um
addiction he's probably a
world-class liar
is he good at that too
no he's a terrible liar but
he gives he gives it a world-class
effort maybe maybe yeah okay yeah um
so you can't you can't
shield your son from the fact that his
dad's about to walk out on him and his
mother
the hardest part is for 20 years
i have been trying to protect this thing
and it's like it's all imploding right
now and i can't i have no control
yeah no anything
that's right
and
the quicker you can exhale and say okay
what about this can i control
and what about this can i not control
the quicker you move there
the quicker your feet you know you've
ever been to the beach and you get
washed out and you can't touch and you
can't touch and suddenly you're like
whoa whoa you should panic a little bit
and then you find footing
even though the water's up to your neck
you find footing and you just go okay
that's the moment you say okay i'm gonna
start trying to control what i can
control here i'm gonna let the rest of
this nonsense go
um cool
so um i got this from my friend dave
ramsey he says the moment somebody says
i'm divorcing you i'm out
this is no longer a relationship this is
not a business transaction
yeah and i will as a part of a business
transaction protect my interests which
include my child
yeah and so
this is the moment when um that old
awful saying you may be through the past
but the past isn't through with you
this is when the conversations about
your infidelity and your financial
infidelity and your
abusive behaviors and your addictions
all that it becomes part of
the narrative that i'm going to use to
protect my child
yeah right nothing personal you said
we're done great now now we're moving
i'm moving forward with that information
and so
do you weaponize somebody's past no but
you you do use the facts available to
you for the safety of your kids so where
do you find yourself you can't control
him his decision to leave his decision
to pull the plug on your marriage and
can we be honest for a second
yeah your marriage has been troubled for
a long long time right
yeah just band-aids over band-aids
that's right so in some regards he's
just throwing the lights on on this
thing right
yeah
and some of it i i told him he had the
courage to do what i couldn't there you
go there you go
and so in that regard
fair enough
whether it's it's you're there's
probably a lot of chicken or egg here
whether your mental illness led to he
thinks to this or
the fact that you've been sharing a bed
with somebody that you were 10 000 miles
away from spiritually intellectually and
psychologically
um contributes to
that
mania and that pervasive feeling that
you're not enough and that just
low-level depression that runs through
your veins right when you're in a
relationship with somebody but you can't
figure out how to bridge that gap
um yeah those things those things feed
each other right
so here you are the lights are on great
i can't stop you from leaving here's
what your life will look like when you
leave
and then you get to decide i'm not going
to put this stuff into your heart and
mind you get to decide what that is
that's what you can control
you can control whether you decide to go
see a counselor starting today
you can decide whether you say i'm going
to
be about exercising every day even if
it's just strolling for a walk
i am gonna triple down on skin-to-skin
contact with my eight-year-old three
times a day four times a day not in a i
need him to prop me up
but in a
this is going to heal him and heal us
both
right this is just a way i'm going to
settle him down you get to decide those
things i'm going to get all the little
debbie snack cakes out of the house and
i'm going to eat well even if i want to
throw this salad across the house like
i'm going to do the things that i need
to do to stay well
because the next season is going to be a
mess
yeah
that's what you can control
and those are going to say with me it's
all i mean that's it that's all you can
do right
i know
there's not a song you haven't sung
there's not a
bar class that you could have gone to
there's not some crazy acrobatic thing
in bed you could you didn't try
it's not that
it's he's choosing to leave
because he's got demons chasing him
and i'm gonna help him so you can love
him
but until he decides he's gonna help him
um
he's gonna just keep running
yeah
and running and running and running
i'm i'm heartbroken for you
and at the same time at the same time
there could be a bright light on the
other end of this thing you know why
you're worth more than all of this
all of it
you're worth more than the infidelity
you're worth more than looking in the
mirror and thinking you're not
attractive enough
you're worthy of knowing where the money
is in your home
you're worthy of not wondering if he's
coming home if he's coming home and
who's these new people and a motorcycle
what you're worth more than all of that
yeah
i am
you are can i tell you one word i want
you to keep in your mind
yeah and you've heard me say it before
i'll say it a million more times you
gotta practice
you're gonna have to practice loving
heather because you haven't you've been
trying to hang on for so long
yeah
will you practice that
absolutely
practice the way you think practice the
way you talk practice all of it so hang
on the line i'm gonna send you a copy of
it's it's just it'll be out very very
soon of my new book on your past change
your future here's the thing is
it's gonna walk you through how to deal
with the the
last 20 years the last 30 years probably
and then it's going to give you us
like here's what we do now
and the book's not preaching at you it's
just me walking alongside you
because i've been in a hole too
okay i'm gonna send you a free copy of
that
are you gonna make a phone call today to
somebody
i will okay you gotta have somebody one
two three seven you gotta have people
who walk with you in this season
they will the waters will get rough
and you'll be able to touch
yeah
and thank you so much hug that little
boy a little extra tight just for me
i will i will okay
yes hey your bravery and your strength
and your willingness just to say what do
i do
there are millions of people in
relationships
that are on the brink
saying how do i get them to how do i get
him to how to get her too
your bravery to have this conversation
today is going to help a lot of people
out there thank you so so so much
check back in with us because i want to
hear how this one plays out